the Joe Rogan experience maybe maybe
this is a good segue I hadn't thought
about this way but so can we use this
format to announce that I am in fact
starting the podcast I've recorded a
couple boom episodes already that are in
the Canon is it is called the portal the
portal yeah hmm
so the portal is refers to this this
very interesting thing that I I thought
everyone was aware of but very often
people wouldn't react to it when I was a
kid I read all of these stories that I
thought were known to be the same story
but different versions of it and I
called it the portal story and it was
always the same somebody is trapped in a
humdrum existence in an ordinary world
until some sort of magical portal
accidentally or on purpose enters their
life and either they go through a
wardrobe they go through a rabbit hole
Looking Glass platform 9 and 3/4 or you
know Dorothy famously was used to
introduce Technicolor where she the
first part of the film she's in Kansas
and it's a sort of grayscale
black-and-white oh that's right and then
she lands in Oz and they opened the door
and it's Technicolor and there's this
transitional scene where you see
Technicolor for the first time was that
the first time ever in a movie I believe
so and so how also the question is
where's the portal like why do we tell
the same story over and over and over
again with different protagonists but
it's always the same formula it's
somebody is trapped in an ordinary world
they're sort of there were around
normies they find the portal and the
portal becomes the call to adventure and
they spend time in the alternate
universe and then somehow they're able
to live very often they return if you
remember the Phantom Tollbooth Milo gets
this present of a car and a tollbooth
and he goes
through the Tollbooth any what is that
from Norton Juster was the author and
Jules Feiffer was did the illustrations
was just this brilliant book where
there's like the land of letters in the
land of numbers so it's arts and
sciences and you know like there's a
there's a person who starts from his
head and grows down until his feet
reached the ground and there's a numbers
mind and he has to rescue the princesses
of rhyme and reason in order to restore
order between the two kingdoms of the
you know like left and right hemisphere
it's some incredibly exciting story and
the idea is that after he goes and does
all of these there's an island called
conclusions and when you make an
assumption you leap to conclusions so
you suddenly jump I mean it's all very
clever wordplay and stuff at the end of
the adventure the Tollbooth disappears
because it has to go to the next kid who
needs you know and so my question was
always why why on earth would we tell
the same story over and over and over
and over and over again it has the same
format and it's always a different
context and I came to believe that this
story is actually this unkept promise
for most people that in their adult
lives they don't find these portals so
for example have you ever been to
Barcelona Spain no there is a church in
Barcelona Spain which is plenty
impressive from the outside when you go
inside I've been looking my entire life
called la Sagrada família it is a
psychedelic drug trip and a half like
you've never seen it is the most bizarre
interior space I've ever seen in my life
can you bring up the interior of this
thing whoa and on the one hand it
induces like a hallucinogenic state on
the other hand it's an idea of what this
architect Gaudi now Gaudi is very famous
he did a lot of buildings around
Barcelona there is nothing like the
inside of this church on this planet and
Wow
[ __ ] that's beautiful and if you look up
at the roof
Wow and like you know most things you're
sort of prepared for them your whole
life and then you see it and you think
yeah I guess I guess that's cool I've
been seeing this thing my whole life and
I had no no concept of what a genius
this human being was because nothing he
did really outside of it the outside of
it I mean look this guy didn't if he
never did the inside of this church he
would be a very famous an idiosyncratic
architect Wow but they didn't work on
there they haven't finished it and in
fact he's such a such a genius that they
can't finish it in the style that he
started it because nobody knows it's
like an unfinished symphony what would
you do nobody's smart enough to finish
this church Wow look at the roof on that
okay now that is a portal out there that
is a portal right and when we when when
I was on this program before you know I
thought long and hard what is it that I
could push out to the planet to let
people know how wonderful and beautiful
the world that we live in is and we
pushed out the hopf fibration and
suddenly if you recall I said to people
this is the most important object in the
universe not the hopf fibration in
particular but the class called a
principle bundle which people have no
idea it's out there and it is the basis
of the construct in which we live so how
is it the normal human being can make
contact with real physics with you know
real beauty of biology or you know just
understanding order symmetry all of
these things that are beyond normal
experience and what I hope to do with
the podcast is to have amazing guests
and interesting conversations but just
oh thank you for that that guy was on
drugs that guy was he was drunk yeah
well that's you know remember that's
what Dali said somebody said dolly do
you take drugs he said I am drew
right another Spaniards Spaniards are
really something but that is very
similar to psychedelic states well maybe
some people have access to them all the
time right in part well there's no this
is actually an illustration that sits
above our sink out there a guy who has
tumor in his pituitary or his knots
pituitary gland his what is the one that
the one that they think produces DMT
what the [ __ ] is it called not the
pituitary gland no pineal pioneer thank
you he has a tumor a spot thank you
tumor in his pineal gland and so he he
accesses these states all the time so
this guy has it's a hundred percent DMT
inspired artwork I mean if you look at
it that's like what you see when you do
DMT trips it's like it's a version you
know in the in his style of art but you
you can see the the you can see the
signature yeah DMT there it is there's
his artwork what is his name Sean
Thornton Sean Thornton Thank You Sean
thanks for the artwork it's [ __ ]
awesome it's it's in our kitchen I'll
take a picture of it later and put it
online but that's his stuff like that's
super DMT like that's amazing I mean
that's a thing
a trip to mean type experience like you
could say like Alex gray is probably the
most representative I would say he's the
most representative in terms of artists
in the the DMT space in terms of like
tryptamines and psilocybin and things
along those lines and so if you think
about psychoactive chemicals some of
them are stupefying but some of them are
portals and this concept of if you look
at a wall how do you know that the wall
doesn't have a door how do you know that
there's no panic room behind the
bookcase if you just pull out the right
book we are we learn to stop looking for
the portal and I think when I what I do
differently than other people is that I
became obsessed with exits that there
are other worlds and they're real that
this this mythology of the looking-glass
and the rabbit hole
the matrix is metaphor for very real
things
[Applause]